I was I was a fine art painter at school
in London in 76 I was working with bands
part of that whole punk movement I
started doing record sleeves for the
bands started being asked to make music
videos for the bands I've seen record
C's for and without really knowing what
it was I was more interested than in art
and camera so I was a designer and and
really it just was a series of of things
I thought I was working music videos in
London and then I came to music videos
in LA right at the beginning pre and TV
and those directors started making
commercials so I worked with David
Fincher for about a year doing as he
transitioned into commercials and then
those commercials directors started
making movies and started working with
them I think that you know there's a big
mix-up I heard bill talking about this
between art director and production
designer I think Hank there's a there's
a long tradition and I think it starts
in the way that the film is taught
design for film is taught that that you
are somewhat of a service industry for
the director and and the producers to
just build sets further whatever scripts
are being written so I think that I
think that fundamentally the job is
changing anyway but I think it's always
been part of this very interesting
creative triangle between the director
cinematography and cinematographer and
designer where the kind of inceptive
process actually starts the change in
technology has had this to my mind a
fundamental liberation of the creative
process
I'm not adept at any kind of digital
photography digital technology but I am
enormous ly interested in how much more
easy it is to translate the abstract
visual idea into something that's
material and
be put in front of the lens what can be
explored cinema so graphically and I
think that because the the enormous
increase in complexity of the visual
space now and that's got a lot to do
with where all of our media are sort of
flowing into this very broad world now a
kind of transmedia space where you don't
necessarily know when you start a
project what it's going to be in terms
of a medium you've got to have this
sophisticated way of grabbing the ideas
of creating a space where visual ideas
can be explored
you